hiya folks I'm multiple nazy AK and this
is top five here we countdown the best
and worst performances from our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
everyone's favorite human punching bag
Sylvester Stallone Sylvester Stallone
has had quite the career for himself
from oscar-nominated screenwriter and
actor to Razzie winning actor and back
again is even going to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in next year's
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the 70
year old has been known for his subpar
performances and films but let's not
forget when Stallone is casted in the
right part he can be a fantastic actor
and these are his top five best
performances number five Johnny Kovac in
fists this was a not very well known
film from 1978 and was Stallone's first
time back on screen after rocky
catapulted him to stardom two years
prior he co-wrote the screenplay and
actually shows off some pretty good
range here as Johnny tobik loosely based
on Jimmy Hoffa at two very different
points in his life Johnny Kovac works in
a warehouse and grows tired of the
unfair policies in place leading him to
start a riot though Kovac has fired his
spirit wins him the admiration of others
and he becomes a new recruit for a labor
union known as the federation of
interstate truckers as the union becomes
more powerful Kovacs influence grows and
eventually his ambitions result in a
partnership with the mob however as
Kovac deepens his criminal ties his life
grows more dangerous there are points in
this where Stallone plays Kovac
somewhat like rocky if he was leading a
large group of underdogs and those
moments work great it's easy through for
him and his friends early in the film
Stallone shows off his trademark charm
and plays a bit of a schemer here a
little bit of a departure for what works
for him but he plays this pretty well
great areas are well present in this
character Kovacs
does what he has to do throughout the
film he was pushed too far and became
desperate which is where the character's
moral compass begins to stray that inner
struggle is well handled by the young
Stallone and he absolutely deserves
credit for that about two-thirds through
the film jumps over 20 years ahead
the 30s to the 50s and Sloane gets to
play call back anymore advanced age he's
still good as the elder version but that
portion of the film goes on a touch too
long and the longer it goes the more
flaws in Stallone's performance are made
visible if the movie was about 20
minutes sure this would have been a
hidden gem of a role for young sly but
as is it's still one of his best
performances if you're a big Stallone
fan go ahead and seek this one out I
think you'll definitely like it
number four John Rambo in first blood
arguably Stallone's most popular
character John Rambo has been tied to
slide for 34 years and it's easy to see
why he's perfect for the role quiet
vulnerable yet a mega badass he is the
quintessential
action hero and Stallone's best
performance as John Rambo is still in
the very first film in the franchise
Vietnam veteran and drifter John J Rambo
wanders into a small Washington town in
search of an old friend but is met with
intolerance and brutality by the local
sheriff when he and his deputies
restrain and shave Rambo he flashes back
to his time as a prisoner of war and
unleashes his fury on the officers he
narrowly escapes the manhunt but it will
take his former commander to save the
hunters from the hunted sly has always
been great at conveying emotion with
just his face a lot of the times no
words are needed he can effectively
emote with just a glance and we can
right away tell what he's thinking that
is evident in the very first scene of
the movie when we see the last ounce of
hope leave Rambo as he finds out that
his last friend is dead we can see
everything with just his face no words
necessary the building up of Rambo's
rage is probably the best part of the
whole movie
he tries reasoning he tries holding back
but when the ignorance is too much he
snaps great action and stunts are
constant here sly is great and
believable in these guerrilla warfare
scenes something that he's always done
very well everything comes to a climax
in that final scene when we see his
former Colonel Trautman finally talking
Rambo down the monologue that follows is
still one of Stallone's best of his
entire career it's sad it's emotional
it's maddening but most importantly it's
believable you're the last an elite
group don't end it like this back there
I can fly gunship how you try the tank
house in charge of million-dollar
equipment back here I can't even haul
the jumpin fucking cars Stallone had a
hand in co-writing the script as well
which itself was adapted from David
morals 1972 novel all the creative
juices were working on this project and
it's still one of Stallone's best
performances and Phil
number three freddy Heflin in Copland
when people defensed alone as a good
actor they usually point to Copland and
there's a reason for that
Stallone's understated and selfless
performance reminded moviegoers and
critics that he could still be a great
actor when he's cast in the white part
when a hot-headed young cop accidentally
gets involved in an ugly racially
motivated incident his uncle ray Donlan
a corrupt new york city cop attempts to
sweep it under the rug by helping fake
his nephews death the bungled cover-up
leads to investigations by idealistic
internal affairs officer Moe Tilden and
Freddie Heflin sheriff of the suburban
New Jersey town were Donlon and his
fellow crooked policemen lit the first
thing people usually notice about this
role for sly is that he gained a
considerable amount of weight make no
mistake about it this isn't Rambo he
looks and acts very different from what
we're used to seeing him as Freddy is a
soft-spoken damaged character even more
so than these similar parts he's played
before
once again sliced subtle facial
expressions make this character
memorable in a film filled with great
actors and performances Robert DeNiro
Harvey Keitel Ray Liotta and more all
have great turns in this movie Stallone
downplays his usual trademarks and is
willing to let other actors shine in
scenes with him this is a great
character form and I really wish you
would do more like this also the
chemistry with Stallone and De Niro is
really fun to behold they should do more
movies together
number 2 Rocky Balboa in Rocky
it's the roasts alone was born to play I
know it you know it and everybody who's
ever seen it knows it Rocky Balboa and
Sylvester Stallone are almost
indistinguishable from each other and
sincerity is very important for Sly you
can tell when he's not believing what
he's saying in 1976 is rocky you believe
every line that's read Rocky Balboa a
small-time boxer from working-class
Philadelphia is arbitrarily chosen to
take on the reigning world heavyweight
champion Apollo Creed when the
defeated fighters schedule opponent is
injured while training with feisty
former bantamweight contender Mickey
gold mill rocky tentatively begins a
relationship with Adrian a wallflower
sister of his meatpacker pal
Polly there really shouldn't be much I
have to say about this performance if
you haven't seen it you're doing
yourself a disservice go watch Rocky
it's one of the best American movies
ever made in Stallone is the main reason
why he penned the script and
choreographed the boxing scenes along
with starring in this he would also go
on to direct four of the six sequels his
performance goes beyond the cultural
impact that this character is made it's
deeper than the quotes you know although
they are fun to say from the first
moment we see rocky we are all connected
to him we feel sympathy for him we root
for him we see ourselves in him how he
sees the world how he engages his
friends and enemies we can't take our
eyes off him for a second that's why
he's one of the most beloved movie
characters in history
the scene with little Murray is a great
example of this he's trying to help out
his friend's little sister he
legitimately cares but when he tries
it's thrown back in his face his whole
life has been like that up until this
point when Apollo chooses him to defend
the title against this is where the
twist comes in how does a guy react to
something like that he turns them down
he doesn't think he's worthy of that
shot and that's the perfect reason why
he is the people around him also make
him better Paulie
Adrian Gazzo even Apollo they make rocky
the character and the movie even
stronger the chemistry with this cast
was off the charts sly filled this
performance with all his best little
subtleties his body language the little
comments he makes they all make rocky
more endearing it's the best underdog
story ever self-respect
self-worth and proving something to
yourself is what is gained in this tale
I can go on for hours but the best way
you can see what I'm talking about is to
just go back and watch the movie believe
me you won't regret it
and the number one best selves Esther
Stallone performance is Rocky Balboa in
Creed am i cheating with this the answer
is no let me tell you why I had to put
slide performance in last year's Creed
as the best of his entire career this is
9 years after the last installment and
rocky is in a totally different place
than he's ever been in the edition of
Apollo's illegitimate son Adonis showing
up after all these years makes things in
his life that more complicated it brings
up emotion in him we've never seen
before and also builds off the
characteristics that we've seen in the
previous six installments in this series
Adonis Johnson never knew his famous
father boxing champion Apollo Creed who
died before Adonis was born
however boxing is in his blood so he
seeks out Rocky Balboa and asks the
retired champ to be his trainer rocky
sees much of Apollo and Adonis and
agrees to mentor him even as he battles
an opponent deadlier than any in the
ring with Rocky's help Adonis soon gets
a title shot but whether he has the true
heart of a fighter remains to be seen at
the age Stallone is at he can take these
supporting roles and come off looking
better than ever
this was the perfect use of rocky he's
not the main character a younger fighter
and Adonis takes his place while rocky
fills the role Mickey did for him 40
years ago because we know so much about
rocky at this point and have been with
him since the beginning every word he
says carries so much weight and Stallone
hits a bull's-eye with every scene huge
props the director Ryan Coogler for
telling a near-perfect story with
familiar and new characters mark my
words
that guy is going to be around for years
to come if this doesn't convince you go
back and watch Fruitvale station
besides the effective emotional scenes
Stallone also brings in really funny
little bits into this performance those
bits are present in 2006's Rocky Balboa
but they're brought to a new level here
they're just sprinkled in enough to be
legitimately funny but not overdone
Michael B Jordan is also a big reason
why Stallone is so amazing and Creed
they're layered back and forth and
complicated relationship makes every
scene something to see Jordan really
should have been nominated for his turn
as adye's in this Donnie and Rocky's
friendship goes through its ups
downs as it should and rocky dealing
with his own personal issues here makes
his performance even better creed makes
Rocky Balboa viable forty years after
his initial run in theaters honestly it
may be his best rocky one made rocky the
underdog everybody relates to the
sequels added to his saga and
relatability they cemented his iconic
status but Creed made Rocky Balboa a
legend and there is no way I could have
ranked sli's performance in this any
lower than number one I want to hear
what you guys think what is your
favorite Stallone movie and performance
who do you want to see me cover next on
the show leave a comment and let me know
next week we're looking at the top 5
worst Sylvester Stallone performances
put to be honest after seeing how great
these were it can't be that bad who are
you people
Oh No
you